what up this is token check me out on a
bootleg cave pop uh damn i'm about to
pull a blue face let me do it again what
up this is token and check me out on the
bootleg cave podcast
yo bootleg kev show we got a special
guest here my guy token hey
your new album sorry it's officially out
man your major label debut yeah
how's it feel man
um
it feels
i don't know it kind of feels the same
like i mean i just been working on it
for so long so
it just
it just feels good to be out i've been
working on the music for so long and
i'm just
what feels the most different is that
people just finally have it and
like your fans have been waiting for
this for a while so long yeah and like
it just feels um
i'm just happy to have it and breaking
it down and listening to it
that's the most i'm excited about you
said on the album that you signed the
deal when you lost your ambition
yeah
yeah it wasn't like i signed a deal when
i lost my ambition were you when you
signed the deal maybe you were in a
tough place as far as when i signed a
deal i was in a great i was in a great
place like when i when i made the
decision i was going to sign
but um
no where that line came from was just
what was happening in my life and
basically you got to like listen to the
the album as a whole to like understand
it but it wasn't it was it had nothing
to do with my career like
the last two years have just been like
crazy for me like
i've grown up a lot a lot has happened
you know like the beginning
a lot of people know me from [ __ ] i did
as like a teenager so
just like like turning 20 and like the
last two years for real i just been like
crazy so you're not even 21 yet no i'm
23 now oh wait what the [ __ ] i'm like
so
what that line is about it's just like
i was really for real just like dealing
with
the catalyst of it was like my first
breakup that i ever like been through
um and that just like
it showed me a lot by myself because it
was like the first time like
i just i don't know i was like really by
myself and i learned a lot about myself
and um
it just
it just woke up all these parts of me
that i haven't seen since i was like
real young
so at that time like it was just weird
how so many things were happening at the
same time it was like
this my first relationship ended i got a
crib i got a whip i got the deal but i
had no one to like really
share with you so it was like a lotta
and then [ __ ] gone with my mom and then
my sister and it was like i kept getting
tested
and then i just i just really like it
was a journey bro but
it turned out amazing because like i
just feel like
i feel like i'm not living through
my career really anymore because when i
was younger
you know a lot of people know me when i
was like a teenager i'm like you're
trying to hitting every cipher going
crazy rapidly
trying to improve myself like i'm just
trying to make it i forget what tour i
what toy what tour were you on early on
um
i saw yep yep yeah i was on just like
just trying to prove myself just trying
to make it
um
and it was honest at the time but
um
like now it's just not about it's just
not about like proving anymore like i
don't really feel like i have anything
to prove and whether people like know it
or not i'm not here
because
of how i can spit like people might not
know that but i'm here because of like
the way i write and my perspective and
and the life i've lived
and now it's just feels like everything
at this point is like synchronizing like
i really feel i'd really feel me again
like i don't feel like i'm living
through my career my last project i know
i'm written but
bro my last project
you know is is i feel this way because
of my career this girl looks at me
because of my career it's literally
called between somewhere it's like i'm
between fame and a normal person it's
like i'm
all this is because
of my career and then with this one it's
just like bro i feel this way because
i'm me
this people
this person looks at me because i'm me
like i really feel me now i forget what
the [ __ ] you even asked no no but what
you just said um we know a lot of people
who we're probably fans of who can rap
really really good but don't have any
real fans like they're like they don't
they can't tour they can't sell merch
but they could rap really good so when
you said like
i'm not here because like a rat i mean
yeah you obviously you're very talented
right but you're obviously people relate
to your story people connect with you as
a human being more than anything which
is why you actually are at this point
because if you if you didn't have a fan
base if you you know you probably you
what are you gonna you probably rapping
and doing a day job working at a call
center i'm just i'm just lucky to have
the the fans i do for real like the
you know that just love me for me and
you know i've gone like
viral with just the rapping [ __ ] but the
reason i can sell as many tickets i can
and the reason like i just have this
base
is is because
i i think
it's it's
i'm gonna need to be like 40 to like
really wrap my head around like my life
and everything that's going on but
but i think it's just because i'm just
my like i'm just trying to be tell the
truth and especially with this new album
like there's a lot of truth telling on
the album man that was that was the only
problem
unadulterated just i was like [ __ ] he's
letting him he's letting some [ __ ] fly
i'm just at the i'm just at the point
now where if it's just not the truth
it's just not fire to me like there's a
lot of things i'm trying to accomplish
like of course i want to
make the best records like be a bigger
artist like of course i'm trying to do
that as well but
[ __ ] i could just
for real when i was younger i could just
like
not tell the truth easier like when
you're young like you lie like i i
wasn't that far from like lying to my
mom about like what i'm doing and [ __ ] i
was just used to more not that i was
lying but
you know i used to rap like
i to rip i want to beat these rap
rappers and competition like but for
real in reality i never looked at this
[ __ ] like competition i don't give a
[ __ ] what every anybody else is doing i
just knew people were like into that
[ __ ]
now it's like every time if like i think
of a line and it's not true i can't say
it it's like
it's not fire to me unless it's just
like
the truth
yo um
the it feels like the breakup you went
through
motivated a lot of this music and i
always say through heartbreak we've
gotten some of the best
just music in general ever you know my
beautiful dark twisted fantasy uh we
could go on and on down the line but
like
um how much of
that specific situation was like the
catalyst for just the inspiration of the
project um it was just that it woke
you know when you're in a relationship
you kind of i shouldn't speak for other
people like for me like i was just it
was really a part of me it was like part
of my identity and i was in the thing it
was like my first relationship
and i made a lot of mistakes with it and
like i strung this girl around and [ __ ]
and like she so she was like a big part
of my life for a while and it wasn't
that i'm so sad about this breakup it's
that it being by myself for the first
time like
it woke these things up in myself
and you know i had to go down some some
like negative shits like that's what the
whole like pink is better is is like
pink is like
represent it represents a lot but it's
like the balance of these two two sides
that are these two like roads i went
down to within the last within the last
like two years one of them is like this
red hot
fun
[ __ ]
you know have a new crib space i can do
whatever the [ __ ] i want here my
neighbors are so far away like i can
really like have fun like real
fun
for the first time and then
this other thing that woke up with me is
like
just feeling like i never really feel
defeated like i'm a very confident
person but when i was younger i used to
feel defeated like that's what brought
me to music and [ __ ] i used to just like
want to give up bro for real and um
and what the breakup did was made me
feel like i failed in something
and then that's feeling of failure
that's what the line you brought up is
connected to like it just made me feel
like it just reminded me of like what it
even feels like to like damn failure is
an option
and it led me down this road of just
like feeling like i'm
not that i would give up but just like
down on myself and that represents like
the white side like the white flag side
like giving up and [ __ ] so that's kind
of what the whole album was like themed
about these two rows i went down and the
whole album was like
you know i want people to like decide
their own [ __ ] about it but it's really
about finding the balance of you can
still have fun you can still be in touch
with your emotions but don't o d on it
like i i have a tendency to oh dion [ __ ]
like listen man i think that uh this is
the kind of project that like
could change your life because i feel
like there's not a lot of music coming
out that is very relatable that people
are very vulnerable on that are like
honest
and you're very honest on this body work
talk about this caught on camera record
huh no one asked me about that one yet
yeah the caught on camera record yeah
now i i listened to it and
did you get caught on camera [ __ ]
some
some somebody what what is this record
about um
caught on camera um
is like the catalyst for my breakup yeah
okay so what happened so you just i mean
listen you put it on the album so we you
know yeah um
yeah she just like saw some [ __ ] so you
got caught on camera doing something
like a was it like a sex tape or was it
like you know you're out and somebody is
put you on the story and you're with a
[ __ ] on this you know that happens like
yes to both of those so it was a sex
tape and that
um
uh
yeah
damn man you're a wild boy
how did it happen wait
some did someone did you have like let's
break down this oh no
was the sex tape on your phone or did
someone send it to her
did i already confirm that it was a sex
tape i feel like i didn't even do that
you just did you said yes to both
[Laughter]
um i don't like subscribe to this by the
way
um but
at that point in my life
um it was just so much new [ __ ] going on
and like what i've learned about
like what i've learned about something
in me is like well my life
is fast and there's a lot of exciting
[ __ ] it's it's moving
um it's like a lot of like crazy shows
and crazy experiences
um
i always try to like match that energy
with some [ __ ] i always try to because
it's like when you get fit because i've
been like
i've had really highs like really big
highs
like i probably lived more than
i should have with this level of fame on
that because like i feel like only
people know me is like my fans right now
but i've lived like a lot of [ __ ] has
gone on so
so
you know i've i've done [ __ ] where it's
like you
if you haven't lived it it it i think
it's just kind of hard to understand but
when these
big highs of like performing and
everybody like needing something from
you
um it's
it's very quick to
for me at least to feel very low
afterward like i've had like shows where
it's like the highest i've ever been and
then i get in the tour bus i just cry or
i just like go in my go to the bathroom
and just like be so down
so
what the only thing that like makes that
makes that going from here to going from
here like
what i tried to do in my life is like
stay the [ __ ] up there with some [ __ ]
and that just makes you make decisions
that are like
not within your character you know so i
think at this point
like i know how to balance it a little
more
the difference is back then
i felt very like
my eyes were so big like like the last
project the last project i'm like whoa
like this girl thinks this and and you
got groupies now
and this money or female fans that are
willing to show you how appreciative of
your music they are but whatever even
it is like you know like
whatever not for sure for sure and i was
like i treated every famous person i met
who was like this is i gotta take
advantage of this opportunity this is so
much bigger than me now
i feel like
i belong here this is what i'm this is
what my this is
it doesn't feel so far-fetched anymore
if this was an interview where i was
doing this like
three years ago i would be nervous i'd
be like make sure you come across the
right way now i don't really give a [ __ ]
because i know i'm here for like
me like this is probably the first time
like this press [ __ ] i'm doing that my
friends are going to watch these
interviews and they're going to be like
that's my favorite yourself yeah
the last one the the i mean i don't
really watch my old interviews but i
have a feeling like my friends would be
like oh i see what he's doing he's
trying to like do his business he's
trying like but now it's just like i i
don't i know i'm here to be me so i'm
just be me that's how i'm really gonna
survive that's how i'm really gonna last
because i can rewrite history i can i
can try to recreate history and rap and
go viral i know what it's like to go
viral i know what it is a million times
do that i've done it i see what it does
it's cool for a week
but if it's not you it it doesn't feel
as good as you think it does what feels
good is this album and even if it
doesn't do what i wanted to do but if
there's some people who say like bro i
love that song that's like someone
saying i love you that's what it feels
like so i feel so much better now i just
feel like because you're like this this
album is me this is this is my life
right now yeah i have nothing to hide
like
that's dope man um
you talked a lot about your family on
the album um
for people who don't know like kind of
give us like a little breakdown of like
where you come from like you know what
i'm saying like where you're from and
yeah and just kind of some of your come
up yeah i'm originally from sandler
massachusetts um but i spent like the
majority of like my forming years in
this like small town marblehead
basically
my parents were together in salem
um
my mom my mom uh was born in my i think
my mom was born in salem for real she
was born in massachusetts and she always
talks about the salem witch [ __ ] so yeah
i would assume she was born around there
somewhere yeah but i but i for real
spent like most of my like i went to
school i ended up going to school in
marblehead because i was staying with my
mom my dad stayed in salem so i was kind
of bouncing back and forth but my my
like friends and [ __ ] that i developed
were in marblehead um
and [ __ ] like
you know
people have it like much more like hard
to me and stuff but i was just always
like a kid who just just felt a lot like
it was like
um
you know i just i just always felt very
like
overflowed like i always i always felt
very different and like it's hard to exp
like i had you know it wasn't the
craziest [ __ ] in my house there's a lot
of fights there's fights about money and
everybody you know i grow up from a
family that everyone's on like
medication and [ __ ] for
feelings and stuff um so that's where i
come from like i come from a very
emotional
family and i think that's why i like
feel a lot but um
you know and i was just a kid who
at a young age i know it sounds stupid
but when i was like fi like starting
when i was like or maybe starting when i
was like six or five like i was just so
sad like every day i woke up it was just
like
[ __ ] this like i just and i know it
sounds silly because you think yourself
when you're sick but i'm telling you
like
every every day i was just like why am i
here bro like
um i just felt like i like there wasn't
a day i didn't like just cry about my
life um and then but really that's what
brought me to writing about it and it
just made me feel so much better i i
literally just felt overflown i had to
write about it
and um it made me feel better so
one thing led to another it found form
in music
and then
my earliest songs are just me like
talking about like
sad [ __ ] yeah i mean i kind of remember
like listening to some of your [ __ ] and
like not really remembering there being
hooks
yeah well it's funny because like i'm
saying when i'm like 10 11 12 13. you
were rapping at that point yeah
i was releasing so i was like on youtube
at 10. um
10 11 12 13 all my songs were like
i'm i'm sad
and then 14 is like no i was like no one
is
no one is listening like i was just
getting like clowned down in school and
stuff and like i didn't get it wasn't
like getting attention right
um and then i ended up like
losing like a bunch of weight at that
age and it's showing me that like um if
you work hard towards something like you
can get it and i'm like what am i
and then i decided like i'm gonna try
this music [ __ ] and then i tried to like
really think about it and i was like
what do people actually want to see and
then i was like oh people just want to
see like that this little white kid can
rap like that's like what i was thinking
and then it started working and it
worked so
yeah so one thing led to another where
it's just like oh they want to say i go
around they want to see i can rap
and just
and now i got this base that like
there's a lot of people that just want
to see me rap but they don't like
the beginning the core of this [ __ ] why
am even doing this why i need this is
because writing about
you you're you're my [ __ ] yeah so that's
what this album is like that's why it
feels like better because i feel like
ben again like i haven't felt like ben
since i was like 13. now you know what
wait wait uh how old were you when you
went on sway because that was that was
i feel like that was kind of like a
moment that probably changed things for
you guys changed things for me yeah i
think i was 17. who was in the room when
you were rapping because there was
someone else there there was tracy g
was there another i feel like there were
other rappers was there another rapper
that was there there were two other
rappers do you remember who they were i
don't but shout out to them i love you
guys no disrespect
they're killing it um
yeah no i i remember seeing that and
being like oh [ __ ] this is you just look
so unassuming and just like like someone
like i grew up with nervous yeah i was
just trying to i just that opportunity
felt so much bigger than me so i just
like had to go crazy
how like when do you feel like you
started to kind of break out of the
quote-unquote because you kind of
had pointed out that people would you
didn't you have a song called youtube
rapper yeah yeah so and i remember that
was like a thing yeah because i'm tight
with futuristic who's from phoenix and
people will call him a youtube rapper
and then there's guys like dax who are
called you know like but i feel like you
kind of break broke that mold um
what are what like when when did that
happen where you felt like you kind of
finally started to kind of shake that
that yeah i don't know if they don't
really ever like
people
people never was like he's a youtube
rapper because they knew like i always
like
had real real like when you listen to to
real songs by me like you would see my
attention to detail well i guess i don't
even know what a youtube rapper is i
guess you made the [ __ ] song but i
don't know me yeah i don't know yeah
i people call me a rapper
like at first at first they called me
like a cipher rapper because i was just
like going around in boston and like
doing cyphers so they just always just
like local people it's like he's just a
cypher and then i started going viral on
facebook and i called my facebook rapper
then youtube and then i did the stupid
[ __ ] on tick tock for at 2020 just to
like feed people
and they call me a tick tock rapper and
then went viral on twitter and then they
call me twitter rapper so they just have
to feel like you've mastered the
internet for sure
yeah it's like at what point can i just
be a rapper yeah but um
or a musician um but uh
so
i don't know i guess i i guess it
depends who you ask like i never
i never i always knew i wasn't because i
sold more tickets than everybody
facts
do you think you hitting the road early
with like someone like hopson and seeing
like how he kind of cultivated that cult
following yeah like did that help yeah
yeah for sure help i toured i like did
some [ __ ] before hopson and then i and
then we did
we toured the world together we did like
um
like a u.s
candidate he's the nicest guy for sure
he's a great guy he's lovely
face and everything yeah um
but
uh yeah and then i just started touring
and then like my manager for real was
like you got a real bass like you need
to tour this
um
and and i just prioritize touring since
you know i always did like i've done
like five tours in europe i don't even
know
and i'm just lucky that like people in
europe like me so it's not just like
some us [ __ ] like i can sell more
tickets in europe than i can in the u.s
what's your biggest market uh in europe
probably the uk we have we did like i
don't even know how many tickets every
single show sold out i sold more tickets
in in like london than i did in my
hometown i was wondering that like
artists who have like huge followings
overseas
like uh
my homie gashi's like
gosh you got to call them gashi
what the [ __ ] is he calling himself now
i i know he dropped the four out of his
name but he's super huge overseas um
like is that like when you when you're
like more popping overseas i guess if
you feel like you're like more hardcore
fans are over there does it is it kind
of weird like um
like a fork in the rotary like all right
well should we like kind of start
focusing more on doing [ __ ] over here
and like
uh
i don't i was all money is green but
there's also like i'm from the us so i
want to really go crazy here well it's
not that it's not that far off it's not
like i'm the i'm a european like it's
not like a [ __ ] european pop star no
no like i got i got fan i got core fans
in the
in the um like you're not gonna go get a
flat in the uk
yeah no no no i uh
you know it's it's it really showed me
like
damn i don't know i don't know what
about it like i wonder honestly speaking
i wonder if it's like you know people
have like other
people love to say like oh people don't
give you a chance because you're white
but i've seen like the privilege even in
a hip-hop sense like i wonder like would
i even be this big in europe if i didn't
look like them like is it my music or is
it like you know what's crazy
you're right because like i remember
in in the 90s and 2000s like
all the alternative rock stations were
playing eminem and we were playing
rap records on rock stations and it's
like
yeah people don't i wonder what's
different about eminem yeah
for real for real it's like people think
that [ __ ] is dead people think that like
you know
you know when i'm not on like certain
lists people like love to say
man they're only doing that because and
it's like bro like you don't even know
like a lot of people like
i mean a lot of people just don't
they don't they don't like feel the
responsibility that i feel like just
being aware
that i'm white in a culture that like is
not for me so i mean that's part of the
reason why i am so truthful
because like i'm not pretending to be
something i'm not and at the same time
as like maybe some of that exists
bro like
you can see [ __ ] from the other side and
it's real life and it's like i don't
expect fans to see that i don't expect
fans to know that but i've seen it bro
and i'm in hip-hop yo stop in the
interview got to tell you about our good
folks at odd socks man listen go to odd
socks official dot com use the promo
code 20 off save 20 off some of the
craziest socks you know they got the
ninja turtle joints
uh shout out to kool-aid you know what
i'm saying shout out to spongebob plus
they got the odd socks basics
these are my boys right here i love
these right here you get the plain black
the plain white very comfortable most
comfortable socks in the world to be
honest you know what i'm saying plus
underwear y'all cheez-it draws
come on what are we doing go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and save 20
off the most comfortable underwear in
the world [ __ ] all that other [ __ ]
you'll be wearing on your ass throw all
the methicas in the trash all that psd
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is all
listen man put the mod socks on your ass
cheeks and thank me later
yo on the on the project uh this record
with little skies which is the only
video that's out right now right no
there's um
i got a video with rico rico nasty high
heels
and then i've been like spacing out the
[ __ ] i saw you put a trailer out for
um no no no that that
this video for high heels chit chat and
sip i just dropped them a while ago
um but the uh on that record uh
shout out to lil skies another amazing
dude man yeah really good nice guy um
you talk about your sister's drug
problem right which is a you know i come
from a family of nothing but uh
just drug addicts and
you know
i've witnessed a bunch of people
overdosed and i had a pretty [ __ ] up
childhood myself but
um
like what what's what's the you know for
people who
are going through that who have loved
ones who are dealing with that [ __ ] like
you know how's that how like what is
some advice you could give them to cope
with that
man um i think like all situations are
different so i don't really think my
sister is like she's one of the most
special people if not the most special
person like in my life like she's
she's like
like it's hard for me to compare to
anybody else because her story isn't
like
some person who got into some [ __ ] like
she's so much bigger than that like at
this point she's tackled it and she's
just back
she's she's like she really inspires me
she's the one like show me music and
everything she's like she's like an
amazing amazing person um so i mean
where the biggest the biggest takeaway
from that whole thing was because i was
dealing with my own [ __ ] at the same
time and
and um
seeing
you know
it just it just showed me like this
shit's in my blood you know like
um
it's not just drugs it's just like it's
just like over obsession it's just like
your family in general like yeah i mean
you you mentioned your mom was eat like
did she have like an eating problem when
you're like usually like yeah just been
around a lot of [ __ ] that's that's um
excessive consumption of something od
and [ __ ] and like
and and um
and i've done that too and and and and
was weird about it is that like in a
sense it's really helped my career
because i i focus the [ __ ] on my [ __ ] on
your crap i'm like bro that's why it's
so hard for me to keep a [ __ ]
relationship healthy because it's like i
just so focused on this [ __ ] like it's
hard for me to like really focus on some
other [ __ ] i'm obsessed like with music
like i'm obsessed with it's hard to talk
about some other [ __ ] sometimes
so like
you know like
i uh you know i didn't touch anything
until
well i was getting like [ __ ] up by
like 10 11 12 13 like really stupid
early but when i was first on what
though just like weed and drinking and
[ __ ] um
but too early like i wasn't ready so
then i was like this isn't for me and
then
when and then do you remember the first
time you smoked weed did it did it hurt
because i remember when i was bro i
didn't get high until i had to smoke
really mad times before i got high it
was weird remember the first time i ever
hit something it was a pipe and i just
remember it hurt my throat bad and i was
like a kid
i don't remember that but i remember the
first time i got high
i felt like i'm uh oh they don't know
they like a little person i felt like a
little person on stilts and um mad
colors and [ __ ] and at that point i
smoked weed mad times so i already
thought i'd been getting high and it was
just a placebo thing so the first time i
actually got high i was like
this is the best weed ever this is like
magical we need to make this [ __ ] last
right um
and uh by the way shout out to you man
2022 little person not a [ __ ] never
yeah yeah yeah see you bro yeah see you
bro we ain't getting cancer over here
[ __ ] anyway go ahead but but uh
yeah and then
i was just little ass kid getting high
like so high
where were you getting your weed from at
that
who was your
plug
this is his name uh no just like some
dude in the hood like a neighborhood or
a homie or whatever sure the statue of
limitations all right at this point um
i don't think it's that you're just
getting high as [ __ ] as a little kid
and then it started giving me anxiety
um
like bad like not sleeping and [ __ ]
uh so then i was like and that it was
around the same time that was happening
and i was starting to focus on music
more so then i took the route like i
just got to focus i can't let anything
mess with my mindset and then i was like
just that kid i was like the sober kid
and then um and then
i started
and then when i told hopson so it was
easy to like not [ __ ] [ __ ] because
yeah because he's a straight edge yeah
um
uh and then you know i grew up and i
just realized it's not really that deep
as long as you like control [ __ ]
problem is i began not controlling [ __ ]
you know did you ever dabble with any
other [ __ ] besides the weed uh not
really no like like like no and i'm not
even a big weed smoker it was mostly
alcohol it was mostly like um
it it's mostly that
uh and just like
it was just um
and it's it was an escape you know like
um
it sometimes it was just like the only
thing
when i when music wasn't doing it was
the only thing that made me feel happy
like i just remember being like
i want to be happy i want to drink like
they were like becoming they they were
they were beginning to feel like
synonymous kind of like i wouldn't
really have a good time without it
and it happened so quick it was like i
was sober recently like
um and they just showed me how quick i
can go places like how quick i can like
well and then all i should have with my
sister and i'm like whoa and then and
then other stuff and and yeah so
so yeah uh you got
uh jid on the album you got benny the
butcher on the album two of the
best rappers in the world as well you
know um but uh who are like some of the
mcs
obviously those two are i'm sure on that
list but who are some of the mcs that
kind of just inspire you that you're a
fan of right now that you're like
people um the people who inspire me the
most
like for this album we're like just in
general man i mean you're a hip-hop kid
so like yeah in general i mean honestly
what i'm i'm inspired by like
um earl sweatshirt i love
um lucky i love
um every time my [ __ ] i'm listening to
now like
bk the ruler
um cardi
but you know i come from like you know
jay and push and right and um
[Music]
and like i'm like a wayne stand like i
only listen to wayne mixtapes like
that's all i was too
sometimes is wayne your goat like
wayne
wayne yay
um
jay
like i don't even know for like maybe
kendrick but like maybe future
but like maybe
uh who am i forget i don't know but like
my three like people i'm like yay has
changed my life for wayne has changed my
life and like jay has like i don't know
changed my life but like really like i
like him i always say if people if you
have biggie in your top five i respect
it he only had two albums yeah so if i
say i got kendrick in my top five you
can't say [ __ ] to me if you're an old
[ __ ] because kendra got
three i mean we're not even including
his mixtapes or section 80 but his
three official major albums are all
classics like yeah it's stupid it's
stupid but um
yeah i went through like a huge uh like
i went to a huge kendrick phase i
listened to him too much and i just
started to sound like him i was gonna
say do you feel like i do feel like
that's a thing right if you're an artist
and if you're like really listening to
so much [ __ ] yeah can it influence you
when you go record your own [ __ ] yeah
well right now well like i said i obsess
over things
no matter what it is it could be the
stupidest thing like those bars i was
eating like i'm obsessed with those
right now but it's a healthy it's like
healthy um
um so like i used to be obsessed with
eminem that's why i used to sound like
eminem that's why i stopped listening
there was a stage where i was obsessed
with kendrick when damn came out i only
listened to kendrick and then i made
like three songs and i released them and
they all sounded like kendrick and
people like you sound like kendrick and
i was like that makes sense i only
listened to kendrick so i like took a
step away and now i try to like now
maybe i don't know who i would sound
like i listen to different [ __ ] now but
yeah what would you say well how about
this
when you looked at your spotify wrap up
for the year i don't know if you spotify
apple music but did you like who did you
listen to the most last year because it
tells you right yeah i listen to cardi
the most because i love a lot of red i
listen to tyler's album the most
um
that as well i listen to west side gun
um and bk the ruler those are like my
and yay i think
shout out to cardi man that's an
acquired taste
yeah i mean cardi just changed my life
bro i was late to cardi and like like i
still am late i'm not
yeah i'm not there yet i don't know if
i'll ever get there but i'm gonna be
honest i listened to a whole lot of red
and i was like
yeah man i'm this just ain't for me yeah
that's the only honestly playboy card is
the only artist that i've ever listened
to where i just
threw my hands in the air and was like
i'm old
this is it it's happened i can listen to
uzi i can listen to the future i can
listen to any of the new [ __ ] little
pump even
when pump was popping and he had a few
of those like few of those records on
soundcloud were fire as [ __ ] the cardi
[ __ ]
it's just i don't know it's not music is
subjective sure the [ __ ] is power to you
to being honest because brian knows i'm
not saying you're old but i know some
old people who like
yeah i get it i just really can't play
barcardi like i get what he's trying to
do and it's like they don't [ __ ]
up probably like they probably live in
like those people your time will
probably live in like williamsburg and
brooklyn and they probably zip locked
just listen music you want it's not that
deep sure the [ __ ] yeah but you got a
[ __ ] eclectic taser from west side
gun to playboy cardi that's that's a
beautiful thing yeah thanks were you
like obviously signing with atlantic's a
big deal but was there ever a time where
you ever considered signing anywhere
else
i'm sure everyone was courting you for a
while you know yeah um
i mean of course it was all a discussion
but i i uh i didn't feel like
listen i'm just blessed to like have
what i've done independently and still
have that independently like
um
so i was just able to money was never
the thing that made me make a decision
like i'm just very lucky to
i'm okay in that in that area so it was
really just about people who i felt like
aligned with what i was trying to
accomplish
um and just it was just timing for me
because i know if i signed earlier i
know i wasn't ready like now
whether it happens this album or the
next album like i know this records on
this album that if the world heard there
would be huge records now it's just like
getting into the world and before i was
never like making
big sounding records like now you know
now it's just and it happened real
naturally i never was like we got to
make a hit like atlantic was never like
that either like it was never on some
you know we we we have an understanding
of like what i'm trying to do i think
they have a lot of respect for
i feel more comfortable going like this
rather than
you know
yeah because i mean on that same record
we're talking about earlier you had said
maybe i'll just let them have someone
write me some hits or some [ __ ] yeah
which is the thing that atlantic has
done shout out to bruno mars
i don't know b.o.b
you remember
yo shout out to atlantic because they
they had bruno mars on every [ __ ]
hook in like 2011.
if i didn't if i didn't uh if i didn't
write my [ __ ] um my people would know
and like but but isn't it okay to get
help with hooks
i make good hooks though no but i'm
saying like let's say you're in the
studio
with like i don't know whoever the [ __ ]
and like
they have a idea for a hook and it's
fire and you execute the hook that
should be all right right yeah i mean
bro people i just don't think you should
ever get help with your verses as an
emcee to me that's like
that's the that's the no-go unless
you're you know i personally wouldn't
but bro like it depends what you're
trying to accomplish because like people
i understand it's like a culture and
[ __ ] but like at the end of the day i'm
just trying to make the best music i can
so someone's got a fire idea in the
studio the problem is i don't think that
much is fire so like it would need to be
something like it hasn't really happened
yet but maybe i don't know i i for me
you know like is it a pride thing you
think or is it more like these aren't my
words this isn't my this this didn't
come from me so i can't maybe it's pride
but like i said at this point
i it's only fire to me if it's true
so it's it's gonna be hard for someone
to write my truth
you know
that's some real [ __ ] that's some real
[ __ ] man um where do you like with this
project um
are you already
working on new music or is this
something you're gonna work throughout
the year or um i'm definitely bra i look
at this album like it's like uh
it's just like the the new chapter has
begun and i just want to keep dropping i
haven't like started i mean i got tons
of records i made after the album was
done that
um
but right now i'm like working on some
some other [ __ ] that's not my [ __ ] um
and uh that's what's happening now but
this this year when you say night your
[ __ ] with me just like
um
[Music]
uh just another i can't disclose too
much but is it music related yeah
[ __ ] super group
um
no it has nothing to do with like my
name i'm just
it's been this trip has been a trip um
are you helping write for kanye or
something
um i don't know
um but i want to make a lot of music
this year was that a nice like shot in
the dark that might be accurate no okay
i just gotta ask because i feel like
every time someone comes to la they end
up writing for kanye west randomly in a
studio session it's like oh [ __ ]
so you're writing for yay that's big
that's big donda two bars down to two
bars huh
i'ma make so much music this year hey so
when kanye reached out to you man like
did he dm you or did he like did he get
in touch with so much music this year is
gonna be so good
knowing yay changed your life what's it
like working with him
i do love yay's music have you met let
me just ask you this have you ever met
kanye west
that's a fair question right without
revealing anything have you ever met the
guy
yes
and is he in was he nice yeah did you
meet him recently
dude i'm so
everything i'll make so much music it's
gonna be so good man the yay [ __ ]
token record is gonna be crazy
like when you because this is a so i met
kanye when i was 16.
my best friend's brother um raqqa
is a part of a group called dilated
peoples
dilated people's
legendary la rap group
um they toured on the college dropout
tour kanye they evidence produced last
call on college dropout
and they had a song called this way
featuring kanye so i met kanye when i
was 16 twice wow um
and i still have the photo
but i haven't met him since
then so like i always think to myself
like
like kanye is my favorite artist ever me
too
and i'm always like man if i ever really
got to chop it up with kanye
like i don't know how like what i would
say to him you know like really changed
my life or like if i ever had the
opportunity to do the interview with
kanye west i feel like it would be
like no one else's interview because
everyone else is going to ask him about
all this [ __ ] going on with [ __ ]
his wife or you know his new girl i
don't care about that [ __ ] i just want
to talk about
some nerdy discography [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying yeah so what was your
conversation like with him when you met
him
um
[Music]
uh i just listened
tight yeah but he knew who you were
i just listened to everything he's got
to say did he know who you were though
um i don't know what he knows to be
honest everything obviously yeah that's
what it seems like nothing at all but
yeah this album is crazy shout out to
token man hey man hey everybody who's
always like why do i need to go to l.a
you may come to la cause you might [ __ ]
around and write for yay yeah what i'm
saying
happened with griselda
they came they were in la
left my spot went to the [ __ ] sunday
service and then we're on a plane to
wyoming within like 48 hours i love
griselda
yeah griselda to me griselda freddy
gibbs like i love freddie gibbs too
yeah man i just love uh shout out to rj
payne shout out to there's just so much
dope ill real rap [ __ ] that's finally
like i feel like the pandemic kind of
brought the world back to listening in
their earphones or listening at home as
opposed to being at the club yeah so i
feel like yeah i think they you know
2020 like they really like it's a hard
reset man yeah and like people who
might not have gotten the attention
before like i think they had like if you
think of those those nominees for best
rap album yeah
royce
j electronica freddy who else got
nominated that year
last year nas
i'm missing someone else who's dope oh
dee smoke
yeah yeah so yeah
shout out to have you ever met freddie
we're gonna make it happen that'd be a
random ass interaction you and freddie i
would love that i'm like a big fan like
i'm a big fan of him yeah um
so the album is out more videos on the
way
yeah more videos come in yeah just and
just like and just next
you know the next chapter like i really
look at this project like i know it's
like my major label debut but the way
i'm looking at this it's like bro just
put in a universe that's the new like
place that people are gonna have the
reference of me and now i just wanna
move on i just wanna keep dropping like
i hope i don't watch this [ __ ] in the
year and i'm like damn i didn't drop
[ __ ] i think i i think i'm gonna though
yeah what you you say you're super
obsessive so besides your music right
now what are you obsessed and those bars
like do you play video games are you
[ __ ] binge watching any tv like what
are you what are you doing when you're
not um pushing this album um aha
sparkling water the the cucumber one and
the um the blueberry one
yeah yeah we're gonna buy those do you
own any percentage of this by the way uh
no [ __ ] but i'd love to um bro that's
how i feel about there's this energy
drink it's ghost energy
and i [ __ ] and the coconut ones i like i
don't know how many episodes i have a
ghost energy can sitting here and
they're not paying me a [ __ ] dime but
i'm like obsessed with these energy
drinks you got to take the rapper off
like me
it's like a yeah i'm like [ __ ] i've been
telling this for like bro we gotta
[ __ ] talk to these people like yeah
i'd like dm their page and [ __ ] and like
yeah i used to have like a thing i used
to like quest bars
quest bars i mean i'll be on the i just
got on the keto [ __ ] so those are
acceptable yeah be careful though
they'll clog you up a little bit
as in like you'll be constipated they
made me constipate a little bit but i
again upset so i'd have like hey i think
they're [ __ ] terrible but yeah most
people don't like it it's like like like
take like like like a flavored piece of
rubber
but you never know like reach out
because i uh i was um
i was like obsessed with quests and like
i post a picture with them and they dm
me and they like send me a bunch of [ __ ]
and i was supposed to be in the
commercial that ever happened but
um you never know what's uh the last tv
show you binge watched i don't really
binge watch shows i like movies more
um
who's your who's like like give me your
top five movies of all time
um mother
um
[Music]
[ __ ] i mean good
fellows um
maybe like scarfy i mean those are the
obvious ones but i really like um
place beyond the pines
um
damn i really like some like somewhat
new like i i really like um i like [ __ ]
like nightcrawler and prisoners [ __ ]
like that they're not my favorites
i don't know what the [ __ ] i just know
two other two other five you've
mentioned i've heard of damn yeah um
man i just watched them oh like eyes
wide shut i like [ __ ] like that
um
[Music]
yeah
have you seen mother
i've heard of it i haven't seen it
mother bro go see mother and like put
your phone away and try to watch on like
a big screen i saw in theaters but like
don't get distracted and really it's
about
it's just crazy it's just a trip it's
just like you just got it's like a
roller coaster you just got going for a
ride and
and like
it it changed the way i wrote all my
music videos like that movie like
inspired all my treatments
you ever seen the big lebowski that's my
favorite movie right there no what's
that you've never seen the big lebowski
no
oh man i haven't seen a lot of like
classic movies it's from 97 it's um it's
a cohen's brother's movie it's it's it's
the greatest comedy ever oh it looks it
looks fun it's a
about a loser in l.a
named the dude i always used to be like
super i didn't [ __ ] with superhero
movies but you know
i hit my friend i was like what's a
charming movie like i was just in i just
wanted to be charmed and he said like
the first spider-man or like the the new
spider-man but the first one and i
actually like kind of liked it it was
very like warming that shit's fire the
new spider-man shits i never i never uh
i just always hate it like i like
hanging fruit man it's like it's it's
okay to sometimes like you could go into
a movie and know it's like
you know what it is
so you just gotta you you gotta like
enjoy it for what it is it's like when
you're in the club
and someone plays some [ __ ] that you're
not gonna listen to in your car but
you're like i'm in the club let me
[ __ ] enjoy this
shitty playboy cardi record you know i'm
just [ __ ] with you
that kid though is very charming um no
yeah tom holland enzende is an
incredible actress shout out to her
euphoria have you watched euphoria yeah
that shit's like [ __ ] kids man i
watch it with my girl she she like loves
it um and she uh
yeah she got me into it i like that show
a lot too she keeps
i'm been here but we gotta watch like
the new one we don't know the new one's
crazy it comes out have you watched the
new episode one of the new seasons i
haven't seen anything new i've just seen
the one the new season the new season
they don't play that [ __ ] comes out what
the [ __ ] damn
it's it's [ __ ] that's a dark ass show
man my girl loves it i like it too but
she loves it it's a good show man well
listen i appreciate you pulling up the
album is out um
looking forward to hearing whatever you
got going on with kanye
and uh
yeah last question if you could do a
collab album
real realistically don't say [ __ ]
jay-z i'm not saying that you and jay-z
won't do an album one day but like right
now
if you could do a collab album with
somebody who would it be
um
[Music]
man like there's like dreams and then
there's like what i think would turn out
good what would you think would turn out
good
um
my
baby key maybe baby keems five
maybe ski
um
[Music]
ski's incredible yeah
i think i think i'm a really big fan of
baby keem and i think he's just like
he's gonna keep like
i just i really like what he's doing i
think he's getting better and everything
like so you know he's almost crazy yeah
and i love like his first album like i
love like honest is one of my favorite
songs off his first [ __ ] so baby keem
token project there it is ladies and
gentlemen i would love it go get the
album
stream it i'm sure you got merch on the
website right yeah um are there going to
be vinyls that's kind of a thing the cds
the sea we put a lot of effort into the
cds and i really gave a breakdown of
like where i was at mentally you do the
pink vinyl yeah we definitely do problem
is adele [ __ ] up the whole vinyl
supply chain with 30.
oh my god yes people are waiting like
six to nine months for vinyl because
they made like more
adele 30 vinyls and they've made for an
album in like i don't know how many
[ __ ] years oh my god
so
yeah good i mean you're gonna probably
have to you'll probably do the vinyl in
like that man right there will take care
of it he looks like he's got a dusty
sick vinyl collection he's the final i
know i just know he's been thinking
there it is man thank you
thank you